oh oh
ah
oh oh man you don't understand how happy
I am to see you you to hello my name is
Markiplier and welcome to help wanted to
I have
struggled a little bit to get here to
this point to see you to see you Gucci
guci guci I've been
wrestling little bit you know how it is
hope that didn't break anything am I
recording can you hear anything have you
heard anything from this game let's
hope oh yeah you're hearing something
okay good good
good Fazbear entertainment is offering a
new on the job training position for a
future Pizza professional we would love
to give you more details but for legal
reasons are unable to without a signed
non-disclosure
agreement Fazbear entertainment
acknowledges that past work conditions
have not been ideal however we can
provide you with a 100% safety intention
guarantee to accept this position press
or say
one we didn't quite get that but we know
what you
intended welcome to the team your first
day starts now thank you thank you so
much for welcoming me here it's so good
to be here finally in this place
again hi there's so much work to be
done
uh-huh use that touchscreen
computer wow it's the future
hello mine thank you thank you for that
wow we're back this is the important
thing to know about this is that we're
back baby and I'm going to play some
Five Nights at Freddy's and I'm not
going to let the past get to me because
I'm here to have a good time I don't
even know where you are but it doesn't
matter because you know where I am and
I'm assuming I'm pointing right at the
other camera I have behind because
usually when I turn around you can't see
me now you can
anyway daab only
whoa cold store whoa Glam Freddy
requires assistance delivering a very
special ice cream cake
okay find and recover Jimmy's birthday
cake from Freddy's chest cavity use the
heat gun to defrost Freddy but don't let
him get too hot use a diagnostic machine
to complete
repairs
uh-huh
um hi this this seems a little arbitr is
someone there yeah my ocular fluids have
crystallized I am unable to process your
appearance although we have just met I
know I am in good hands after all you
are a fazar technician are you
not well please retrieve little Jimmy's
birthday cake and place it on the
birthday
card however I must warn you due to
extreme temperature fluctuations
I am not quite myself at the moment to
be careful uh-huh okay doobie gotcha
um
oh well that seems to be doing the cold
I don't I don't know
about all right it's just a you know how
I set up cameras and now I'm facing the
one one way that I don't have a
camera that's okay all right Faz
power bam all right
sure
SC you
hot you
toasty how about
now is that a little too spicy for
you you said your ocular fluid was a
little
cold I probably can't be too good um so
oh wait there it is
wait wait it's right oh Timmy oh that's
not Jimmy okay well let's put that one
on
Ice yeah it sucks to be you Timmy unless
it's an ice cream cake sucks to be you
Timmy is it just me or is the room
getting
hotter I don't know oh also I don't know
why I have a microphone on my controller
here but it seemed like the only place
to put it because I already have one
here and I wanted a backup microphone
speaking of which is that recording
still yes it
is too spicy okay so what do I do
now have you always had a earring
this doesn't seem to be even be doing
anything what does that
do all right the square
peg wow the round
Peg damn I'm good okay
so I wish I had a light or
something I have this I can't see what
I'm working
on uh
buddy
uh I don't know if that's
normal seems to just be your
hand I'll get that out
there cool down there
buddy what's going to happen are you
feeling warm
oh
well I mean I knew it was going to
happen but still I feel like it could
have been a
little more elegant again I don't know
why I'm pointing this way I would like
to point this
way ah there we go that's EAS once again
I am stuck it is quite embarrassing oh
so you're not going to go through whole
Spiel again that's fair thank you for
that is it just me or is the room
getting hotter n it's just me buddy
wh it was actually I was doing that
intentionally so I knew what the limit
was and that way I wouldn't be all
Loosey Goosey about everything else
there wh can I put that in upside down
too late
now okay what is
that
a
Wham you better not get too hot
cool down cool
down you stop that now tell me that is
very
cold uh heat up I
guess oh it's too
hot done oh
whoa yall right there buddy you okay I
smell a
thumbnail
what the
[Music]
hell oh hi
hello well ain't that adorable but that
is
[Music]
horrible uh I mean I
am I
mean
oh ah
oh oops oh no
ohoo that's the effect is lost the
OHA AOA yeah I know I have that effect
on people
um freaking
oh god oh wait no no hold on hold
on shut shut up shut stop hey what are
you what are you doing stop stop that
stop stop
it okay well I felt like I felt like
that was felt like that might have been
what I was supposed to do but all right
I'll take
those oh my God okay so I'm going to
just I'm going
to oh my
God get out of
here okay so
well I don't really have
that hold on there I don't have that
tool oh it's over there hey hey stop
that God damn it stop give me that
freaking thing stop didn't you say to do
this wasn't this what you said to
do
stop
stop unless I need the circle oh never
mind ah hey you did good today not that
good it is a delicious ice cream cake or
so I've been told I cannot
taste oh my God what's going on I am
receiving a cake removal alert please
find something of suitable size to
replace it
with oh
yoink there you go good job you are my
Superstar thanks thank you
you're
mine oh
yippe I I did it okay and I got that
coin too which is awfully nice it only
took me a few tries everybody knew that
was going to be a little rough but now I
got my bearings again because I know how
I know how to play this game it's
empty never mind do I get
that son of a
please learn to love me what
is what is what is
that what is that why is that under
there what is inside of you I guess it's
intestines if I really think about it
okay well this is getting back into the
swing of help wanted to seems like
there's a whole lot of things to do
check out the pizza place this is a very
important message please check the pause
menu for heighten teleport controls what
do you mean
teleport
wait height adjust mode what do you
mean yeah this is more yes yes
yes yes oh yes Ah that's a maximum okay
well this is actually my true height
so that's cool so good on that oh there
we
go oh yeah this is helpful I didn't even
know that was an option okay teleport
turn okay well I no longer need you can
I get out of height adjust mode please
can I can I get out of well can I get
out of height adjust mode please look I
don't have those controllers I have
different
controllers oh
man finally something that can really
make me feel at home in the virtual
world world can I get out of hide adjust
mode there we
go now can
I can
I oh
shoot oh my God
okay it's all good I don't need to
explore anyway how do
I I adjust Mode come back to me what did
I press I don't have that many buttons
shrink I can't reach I can't see I have
different controllers because I'm not
using the index right now which has
probably been the core of all of my
issues things would have moved so much
better if I had just done that but I
lost the base station for it so I don't
have that anymore so I have to use this
one and it's not working 100% but that's
okay because all I want to do is if I
can adjust height I can get back to the
game I hold it
down okay all right I get I I understand
now
I I I I got well I well this that's not
this
isn't all right I got my height
nowo staff only first aid Pig patch what
are the other ones here holy crap that's
so
many
wow I could play fazer
blast balora gallery that was horrible
I'm probably going to die I really don't
know if I should stay this height it
seems inaccurate but okay balora is
looking for you don't let her catch you
get to the exit quietly stay away from
balora and the oh this is legitimately
the moment from Sister location ah
I see that might that might be a
pro can't see anything for your safety
please make your way to the exit please
make your way to the exit in 5 minutes 4
3 to exit you have to exit that that's
not how countdowns work I can't see
anything what do you mean I I can't see
anything is it cuz I'm too short I can't
even see my hand what do you mean what
do you mean am I on some kind of a time
limit was I sent into purgatory for my
lies I I I feel like it's
broken
uh
oh for your safety please make your way
to the exit okay I'll see you
around that's what the problem was I
can't move because this is broken I'm
pushing it going moving I'm gunning it
here we
go can I adjust my height let's see if
I'm
oh well this isn't right either I I
don't know
if
oh that was hey balora I'll see
see around nerd is someone there not at
all is
someone there oh shoot oh
[Music]
god oh this is ter oh my
God oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my
God oh my God oh my God oh my
[Music]
[Applause]
God oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my
God
[Music]
what do you mean what do you mean oh
that was horrible horrible that was
horror F I don't know what that was
about I feel like they set that up well
here we are again he to just please okay
it it doesn't like me I'm going to
restart that I'm up I'm up there we go
oh for your safety please make your way
to the exit please make your way to the
exit in 5 minutes 4 3 1 minute to you
have okay what do I do I don't know
exactly what I
[Music]
do I'm
gone can't get me if you're I'm I'm
under here
peekaboo oh my God
[Music]
what do I
do what do I do oh my God no no okay
well I I'm
confused I'm a little I'm a little
confused as to what the proper strategy
is supposed to
be I'm just going to not adjust my
height anymore I'm going go from there
hi for your safety
please
I'm guessing maybe I'm just not supposed
to move you'll never expect this make
your way to the is someone there later
nerd INS What do you mean what does that
mean someone is inside hi oh my
God okay well that's interesting I don't
know what that's about you'll never see
me oh
oh my God I don't know where I'm
going what did it mean someone was
inside why was that that didn't happen
[Music]
before I don't know where I'm
going but my instincts say that there's
something back here what what do you
mean okay maybe there's not something
back there or maybe that's just what
they want me to think and I I should
have turned around to be able to see the
things that were back there so that's
what I I do I'm going this way and you
can't stop me for your safety please
make your way to the
[Music]
exit what do you
mean what does that mean
what does that
mean oh okay all right
well okay I went a long way back that
way that did not go anyway now it'll be
easy cuz I I've done it already
so ain't nothing to this
[Music]
one oh my hand touched
you oh sorry I was a I able to go
infinitely the other way and then
suddenly I graze an ankle and all hell
breaks loose that's not fair to
me that's not fair to me at
all I'm just a mouse no more than a
mouse
just tiny don't be
shy what in the world is wrong with you
I guess I didn't hear it Go winding down
usually that's the indication that it's
done that's what I did when I was going
the other way anyway but I think the
mouse strategy Works he's got to be a
little
[Music]
mouse
[Applause]
[Music]
why do
you
[Applause]
[Music]
why why do you hide inside
your
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
Mouse little mouse little
mouse I don't know where the coin was in
there but you know that's okay I get a
prize what I get oh oh
balora it's my
prize man I'm out of breath I don't know
where it would be on the I know where it
would be on that one duh wait a minute
am I an idiot no watch
this whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa who
whoa
he what how was that fair how was that
fair Fair that's not
fair someone is
inside whoa God screw you I'm trying to
get to the stage and I know that's
probably why you're there is because
you're blocking me because I know the
coin is up there you could stop being an
no not again maybe they're just
in pre-programmed locations instead of
just appearing randomly in so I got to
go the long way around the
back screw you
guys oh why
you all right okay I'm not going about
that the right way but that's okay
because that's a mystery for another day
I know it's right but I'm guessing it's
because they can't get my height right
that's the answer and also because I
can't move for some reason I'll figure
that out in the next episode thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
enjoyed this lovely Adventure back in v
it was a little bit of a pain to get set
up again but hey there's no Tech I can't
be check out my other VR FNAF games in
the link in the description below thank
you and as always I will see
you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye